MARKUS KLUTE: Hello, and
welcome back to 8.701.
In this class, we'll
talk about spin.
If you remember the discussion
on relativistic kinematics
we had last week,
you noticed that I
discussed the decay of a
pion, say a neutral pion,
into an electron and--
a positron and an electron.
And we were able to calculate
the velocity of those two
particles, the electron
and the positron,
quite easily by knowing the
mass of the pion and the masses
of the electron
and the positron,
which is served into the
rest frame of the pion,
and we can calculate
our velocity.
I also told you that this
decay is highly suppressed
because of the spins of
the particles involved.
The pion has spin zero, and
the electron and the positron
have spin 1/2, but
it is not easily
possible to align the
electron and the positron
such that the spins align to 0.
So therefore, this decay
is not usually possible.
Now, let's dive a
little bit into this.
In quantum mechanics, the spin
of a particle with a vector
is quantized, and in terms of
its length and its components.
You calculate the length
of the spin vector [? S. ?]
You find that it's
square root of f
times s plus 1 in
units of h-bar.
The components, and along
any axis, actually--
and in this case
here, the d-axis--
have eigenvalues, and
they are listed here.
And we find that there is
2s plus 1 possible values.
So I'll pick here, just
arbitrarily, the z axis.
But the question-- it's
an obvious question--
which axis is a sensible
choice for this problem?
So I want you to actually stop
here and think about this.
What are sensible options?
If you want to get an eigenvalue
with the physical state
of particles, which axis are
the right ones to choose--
or, sensible?
There's no right and
wrong in this discussion.
Let me motivate this.
If you look at the orbital
momentum of a particle,
that's given by r cross
p, where p is the momentum
vector of the particle.
So now, if you're looking
at the total momentum,
we have to look add
the angular momentum
and the spin of the
particle together.
So as shown in
this picture here,
you see that the
parallel component--
the component in parallel
to the slide direction--
is 0 by definition, because
the cross-product is defined--
the angular momentum is
defined as a cross-product
with the momentum.
So this is a nice choice of
coordinate system or of axis--
namely, that is the choice of
the momentum of the particle.
So you find that the total
momentum perpendicular
is the spin of the
particle perpendicular,
and the transverse component
is its angular momentum,
the orbital angular momentum,
and the spin of the particle
in the transverse direction.
This, then, immediately
gets us to a new definition,
then of helicity.
You can define the
helicity of a particle
as the spin of the
particle dotted
with the momentum
of the particle,
and then normalized
by the momentum.
So basically, for a fermion,
which has a spin 1/2,
you get plus 1/2 if the
spin points in the momentum
direction and minus
1/2 if it points
in the opposite direction.
So now, if you go back to our
particle here, off by here,
decaying into an electron and
a positron, spin is at 1/2,
but you find that an electron
is a left-handed particle,
so its helicity will
point in this direction.
And for the positron--
sorry-- for the positron,
it points in the
same connection.
So the pion here is
spin 0, and if you
discuss this in the
rest frame of the pion,
the electron and
the positron fly off
in opposite directions, which
means that the spin doesn't
in align to 0.
So that's why this
is highly suppressed.
It's not 0, because
you can find--
you can put [INAUDIBLE] into the
rest frame, where you're just
basically looking
at both particles
from one side that was coming
to you, and in that case,
it's allowed.
But the spintronic configuration
is highly [INAUDIBLE]..